joining me here on the rich eisen show
to discuss that and so much more
is a guest who normally i would take it
uh
the wrong way when the guest on a
previous show with a fill-in host says
the filling host is 10 times better than
the actual host
but when the fill in host is my wife
it's all good i agree
peter king back here in the rich eisen
show how are you peter
mr schuster how are you doing bye
you're not the first to call me that
charles barkley called me that
on the broadcast of brady and manning
with tiger and phil
and that did not go uh very well over
and uh
well i went over great my house but uh
not uh
especially with my kids so you're not
the first peter it's all good how are
you thanks for doing that i appreciate
it
that was a fun that was a fun show that
day with susie yeah she she
she's having me do that no and she felt
the same way
so um your your comment about uh
russell wilson being a pipe dream for
the bears certainly uh clanked around a
little bit on the old twitterverse
machine
i'll give you the floor on what you mean
by that peter
i mean if you're the seattle seahawks
and you do end up trading russell wilson
tell me what is the uh what's the big
attraction
of trading him to the chicago bears
the 20th pick in the draft i doubt it uh
khalil mack at 30. maybe
uh that's a that's a very very
interesting piece
knowing that khalil mack is still one of
the best pass rushers in football
um and john schneider's been in
in an eternal search for one but
you know nick foles i you know look
to me every other
uh team that russell wilson's agent mark
rogers named
is more attractive than the chicago
bears
and they yeah they just don't have the
capital for it uh
one would say certainly like everybody
else and they also are in uh the wrong
conference if the the
the seahawks had their druthers why why
is this even a conversation though
peter i know there was a deep dive in
the athletic that kind of laid bare some
of this stuff but i
want to give you the floor on that
subject i really think rich
that uh for russell wilson to have
gotten to this point
he is the ultimate team cheerleader
you know for those who don't know he at
least
until very recently ended every
interview he did
and every press conference he did with
go hawks
and so you know that went over very well
with the twelves
up in the pacific northwest um
but i think what ends up happening after
a while
is that you go through the same thing
over and over again
and i feel like russell wilson
just this is this is russell wilson
standing uh at the outside of his uh
you know his house and and just
basically saying
you know respect me listen to me uh
you make me allow me to be a part of
things
and i think rich i think this all comes
down to quite honestly
just the fact that uh he looks around
the nfl
and he sees other quarterbacks who have
a lot more to do with what their teams
are doing
both on offense and like in the game
plan
uh than the power that he has and i
think he wants some of that
peter king here uh on the rich eisen
show um
why hasn't drew brees made an
announcement yet
peter it's very odd i was told a week
ago don't pay any attention to this
kind of story okay um and by somebody
who
who i trust so i'm going to
uh air on the side of
i have no earthly clue why it's taking
so long
but uh i would be surprised
if he plays in uh
2021 but it's a little bit
weird quite honestly that he hasn't had
his press conference
and said i'm not playing anymore um
but i'm going to give it another week or
so before i say
this is really really weird well i mean
there's a new league year coming
um we still don't know what the cap
number is to the point where
tomorrow's uh franchise tag
um i guess line of demarcation in a way
is might be pushed um so
we're gonna have to get an answer i mean
i think we know what the answer is i
think
most of us would be surprised the
surprise would be
obviously him saying uh i'm i'm still
thinking about it and
and pulling a favre in a way um but
you know and then and then playing for
the the lower cap value
and helping out the saints on that and
sort of just giving a
a via con dios 2021 season where
there'll be fans in the states we expect
uh you know i mean that that i'm just
literally trying to go back and forth on
this to try and figure it out yeah i
i have i've thought about it quite a bit
a couple weeks ago in my column
you know i said what are you waiting for
in essence what what's the
what's the issue here uh there's plenty
of
you know that after the there was a lot
of quarterback news for a while and
there's some quarterback news that is
on the burner but it's just on simmer
right now
um with uh watson and wilson but there's
really
nothing to me standing in the way of him
saying something
um i know for a while i think he and his
family are building a home in hawaii
and he was out there with them for a
couple of weeks doing some final
things like that so i know he's had some
personal things
but um i do think
the other part of this is that i really
get the feeling that
the saints want to move on and you know
it's time it's the first day the rest of
everybody's
life so let's all figure out what we're
gonna do
uh as far as the quarterback position
and as far as
trying to make a really really bad cap
situation
salvageable so what it what what is
their next step let's assume that you're
you're your source who you trust and
believe and
uh because they're they're they're
well-intentioned and well-placed
that brees don't make any anything of
this he's gonna he's gonna be
one of our colleagues with nbc sports in
short order
what do they do is it jamis somebody
else what do you got for me my gut
feeling is it'll be what it was
you know all except for drew brees that
it'll be
uh jameis winston taysom hill
and um they'll compete
probably taysom wins the job or probably
i'm sorry winston wins the job
but if he struggles if he gets the
turnover bug
peyton will play uh peyton will play
taysom hill but but again um
i also think one of the things that
you know i know that you know there's
that sean payton will definitely be
looking
at this class of quarterbacks um in the
draft
and although you and i can sit here and
say hey
it's unlikely that any of them get down
into the 20s where the saints are even
mac jones
i mean you never know and they've never
been afraid
of making a trade and i think if there's
some quarterback in this draft
that they think they have a chance to
get
i would not be surprised i mean keep
keep in mind too that
you know there's a lot of talk about
trey lance and there's
such wide disparity of opinion on trey
lance
that um that probably more than any
quarterback coming out this year he's
the one who really needs
a year of uh you know a year to not
play and so that would be another one i
mean are you going to take a quarterback
this year who you think uh there's a
good chance
he's going to play very little um in
2021 so that could end up working in the
saints favor but we'll see
peter king here on the rich eisen show
what are the patriots going to do
i'm so fascinated by this our our friend
tom curran kind of called out belichick
for not having a press conference since
the third day of this year
um that was an interesting column i
always liked reading what he has to say
from new england
what what what what is what do you think
they're going to do with the quarterback
spot
peter you know rich i i just don't know
they've always been an organization that
um you know belichick
often you know he he operates
with the people in his organization on a
need to know
basis and what that means is it doesn't
matter how
high in the organization you are whether
you're
josh mcdaniels the offensive coordinator
you know he's not he he doesn't really
know
i don't think whether bill belichick one
day is going to call him up and say hey
uh we decided we're going to trade for
john doe we're going
we're trained for marcus mariota so
there's your new quarterback
or but you know he is
i don't want to say he's autocratic
because he isn't but
he's oftentimes not going to tell
anybody what he's thinking
until the decision has already been made
so
my gut feeling is he has a pretty good
idea of his
options um i think for a while
quite honestly i think they were
seriously considering marcus mariota
um i don't know whether they still are
but
um you know they're to have to make a
decision
whether they want to take that 15th pick
and maybe try to move up and get one of
these guys
because this is the first time in a long
time that they've been even
in half decent position um you know to
move around in the draft and maybe get
a long-term quarterback so we'll see you
would you would anticipate you would
think that with his relationship with
nick saban that
he would have some pretty good
institutional knowledge
about everything about mac jones so
i've thought all along that that that
might be an option for them at 15 but
we'll see
if they want to just be totally out of
character right and hop all the way up
to try and get into the zack wilson
um scenario the the i'd love to
to hear the phone call listening to him
calling the jets or the dolphins for
their draft choices
i i can't even hear that right here's
the point about that okay
like when i talk to people around the
league
because everybody knows
that number two is zach wilson you know
and not i mean it's not absolute but
it's likely
um then you know honestly if you
if you're there at eight or nine if
you're carolina dead or denver
and everybody thinks that carolina and
denver are very logical places
for a quarterback you know uh trading
from let's say eight or nine to one
would cost you next year's one and
either
this year's two or three so what is it
gonna cost
the patriots going from 15 to 2
or 15 to 3. never mind that
those are both teams in their division
and why in the world would
uh joe douglas or chris greer
want to hand bill belichick is a
quarterback for the next 12 years
it'll never happen literally something
very hot would have to freeze over for
something like that
to happen and i'm not even gonna ask
about you know what the jets are
thinking right now because it really all
depends on what might happen with desean
watson or
you know i mean there's no sense the
reason for the jets to make a move right
now i want
i want to just interrupt the engine
please that
i will be surprised if the jets are very
aggressive with desean watson why
for a couple of reasons number one i
think that joe douglas
sees his roster right now
he's worked with some really smart
organizations
the ravens the eagles most notably in my
opinion
and he has watched general managers
collect
talent over the years and
you know right now the new york jets are
in position
um to basically fill
their roster with a backbone that they
currently do not have
you know to get an excellent offensive
tackle
um this is wither without taking a
quarterback at at two
um they're in position this year and
next
to really uh stockpile
some really good talent to surround
either sam darnold
or a quarterback in the future with and
i just
the people who know joe douglas are very
dubious
about whether he's going to trade the
world uh to houston for deshaun watson
peter king from nbc sports
um and uh the football morning in
america column which is fantastic right
here on the rich eisen show you
mentioned the eagles being a smart
organization and i
i totally would agree with that although
i am wondering what the hell is going on
right now
you know hey you know they're very smart
they're
they're an a student who just had a d
minus
test who just you know right who just
blew a test
but i still think they're a smart
organization it's just they're on a
really bad run right
well i'm sure you saw what mort was
reporting that jeffrey lurie has put his
considerable
thumb on the scale to say i want jalen
hurts to to
win this job i don't want a quarterback
competition i want this guy and the
question is is why
why would nick siriani not with the guy
that you won a super bowl with i mean
why
why entrust this crucial decision to
somebody who's never done it before
rather than the guy who knows the city
and knows everything and
and also then what the hell happened in
the fourth quarter of that game was it
really tanking for draft position
and then why would you bring in a guy
from the colts organization
um that can fix wence technically
and then send wence to the guy that is
uh
from your organization now at the colts
to help fix once i
i just don't i none of this adds up
peter none of it so i'm trying to figure
it out you know when
when when the eagles were
interviewing and they when when they
were down to nick ciriani
and josh mcdaniels uh for their
their final two candidates
part of the interview was not
we're trading cars and wins
you know that because obviously that
happened whatever
a month or so uh there was there was
time between the time they hired the
coach and
they made the wentz decision so
um i think that
there were probably meetings and
things said between the two sides uh
wence and his people
and then howie roseman and his and the
people at the eagles
that basically the eagles viewed that it
was an untenable situation
and look i think that the eagles quite
honestly
i think there is part of the
organization
and i mean obviously they're not still
in shock but
you know at the end of this season when
they realize my god
we might move on from the quarterback
and the head coach
who eight months ago we were sure
would be the quarterback and the head
coach of our team for the next five
seven ten years right you know they were
joined at the hip to be long term they
were going to be andy reid and
and mcnabb and even better than that and
and longer than that and so i think
there's still a little bit of a shock
that it came to that point both with the
head coach
and with uh you know and with
with wentz and i don't think it says
very good things about carson wentz
quite honestly
i think that um you know when you get
punched in the face
you need to get up and punch somebody
back in you know
and i'm i i i just think that
wentz's response to significant
adversity
was to say i want out instead of
i'll show you i mean what does tom brady
say in 2014
when they take jimmy garoppolo in the
second round to be
their quarterback in the future you know
what he says
i'll show you this guy's not even
getting off the bench and for the most
part he didn't
and brady in in the in the next four
years in the four years that
garoppolo was in new england he won two
mvp or two
uh super bowls and an mvp and what did
aaron rodgers do when they took jordan
love he said
i'll show you what's going to happen
with jordan love he's going to sit on
the bench for the next three and a half
years
and then you're going to trade him just
like he did the patriots did with
garoppolo
you know i'm just telling you you know i
i don't understand why
you've been hurt twice early in your
career your carson wentz
you've been hurt twice and your team no
longer has
the guy who puts on the superman cape to
go save the season in nick foles
you've got nate sudfeld and josh mccown
and
whoever but with the philadelphia eagles
i'll argue this to the day i die
the backup quarterback when carson wentz
is your starter the backup quarterback
is a top 10 most important player on
your team
you need a quarterback who can come in
and save your season if again carson
wentz goes down with an injury
and i don't i do not understand anybody
thinking well
yeah they drafted jalen hurts uh to be
there to be their quarterback
they never drafted him to be their
quarterback over carson wentz
not until carson wentz talked his way
out of town
you know and just putting it all
together peter before i let you go here
um you know we
i can't help but think this just putting
some connective tissue together right
that that we've all been
i don't want to say mort's been used
okay but i just did
by saying i don't want to say it but
we've all been you know given
information to put out there
or and and we all think this is a bona
fide piece of information that should be
put out there
i can't help but think let's put it out
there um make it think like jalen's our
guy
but then call our old friend joe douglas
for
uh zach wilson number two overall and
and pull the trigger on that and that's
the way that they're going to actually
move forward in philadelphia because
you're sitting here wondering what's the
what's the connective tissue that you
can call up joe douglas obviously
anybody has his number and he'll take
the highest offer
but maybe that's the way they go about
it right
i i i just don't i i don't know
it could be because look you know i
wrote about it last week i wrote about
zack wilson
you you had his coach on he's he's a
really really intriguing player
and he's gonna he's gonna get picked
very high
and there are people right now in the
nfl who really
believe in zack wilson and they believe
in him
as a year one starter in the nfl now
whether philadelphia believes that and
whether they will offer the best
here's a question for you if you're joe
douglas
do you go down because you're gonna have
multiple opportunities to go down
do you ignore everything and take the
guy who you think's gonna be your
long-term guy
get a two for for uh sam darnold and
just move on
uh with uh you know with a still a
treasure trove of picks that still
include
or would still include uh two ones this
year two ones next year well let me
answer that question for you peter if if
you'd like if you like a quarterback
other than wilson
and you believe in somebody other than
zach wilson and then you move down to
nine and you could you could take down
that guy down at nine
everything you're hearing is that there
is no uh
there is no there's no kid from ohio
state he can rush the passer
generationally uh well you know
available at number two which has been
that spot
uh in recent days there isn't there is a
generational defensive player in this
draft
right not even close at all so if you're
if you could take somebody's picks you
don't go
any further down the nine go and use
that you still have a first rounder as
well
you could get somebody else from uh for
darnold on the second night of the draft
just like
you know just like the cardinals did for
josh rosen and play it that way i mean
you could absolutely play it that way
look the jets i think the jets are in a
really enviable position
because what if just what if what if
they stay with darnold for one year you
know forget everybody said well
then you'd have to worry about the fifth
year option they're not
exercising the fifth year option it
would be foolhardy
you're not doing that all you're doing
if you keep sam darnold is
you're giving him one year to prove
himself and then if you got to pay him
after that one year you figure out a way
but if you keep sam darnold and he's
your quarterback this year
the jets under almost any circumstance
would have three ones next year
one of them would be their own one which
would probably be a darn good one
and so you would have an opportunity
next year uh
and everybody says well the quarterback
crops a lot better this year
look that is such a silly way to look at
it
because you have no idea who's coming
out next year
and one year ago today
zach wilson was in a three-person
competition
for the starting job at brigham young
after having a horrible end to his 2019
season
so no one knows what the draft is going
to look like at any position
never mind quarterback next year so i
i still think that part of what joe
douglas can do
is he can say say in his building look
sam darnold's never had anything close
to a fair chance
let's give him a fair chance you know
let's draft the
uh let's trade down to number eight and
take the northwestern tackle
and now we got two bookend tackles and
now
it's a fair fight for sam darnold peter
you're the man this is great let's do
this
a heck of a lot more often than the news
is we know is gonna just start
going off the charts appreciate the time
as always thank you
okay rich have a great day that's peter
king at peter underscore king
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here